bonjour madame combler cette question' à
ces soirées violences faites aux femmes
ce questionnaire c'est un violent tôt m
un outil de mesure des violences
psychologiques et physiques au sein du
couple
cet outil permet de se situer de voir si
on est dans la zone verte ce qui est
très bien ou vers la zone orange ou là
il faut commencer à réagir et la zone
rouge où là il faut vraiment partir et
se faire aider
ça peut être un outil qui qui amorce de
dialogue
l approche de la saint valentin le
collectif nous tout soixante dix huit
s'est dit que cette fête des coupes
seraient meilleurs sans violence ils
sont 30 à distribuer 3000 violente au
maître tout le week-end dans six
communes des yvelines
notre but est plutôt d'attirer
l'attention et des veillées et puis
aussi les permettent à certaines
personnes qui n'osent pas aborder les
sujets dont peut-être d'ouvrir la
discussion ou de les aider à prendre
conscience des climats des violences
qu'elles peuvent vivre
je pense que l'outil pour une prise de
conscience oui c'est très bien je trouve
que c'est bien ça quand même ça permet
quand même
aux gens de dévaluer en fait parce qu'on
peut toujours se dire voilà c'est non il
va il va changer c'est lorsqu'on se dit
et puis en fait ben non il s'enflammait
et effectivement ça permet de mettre des
mots sur des actions et sur des
ressentis le collectif nous tout des
yvelines envisage déjà de recommencer
l'expérience pour poursuivre la
sensibilisation prochaines distributions
prévues devant l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines à destination
des étudiants depuis le 1er janvier 2020
dix femmes ont été tuées par leur
conjoint ou ex conjoint dont une dans
les yvelines
selon le collectif